david ce soir est ce que pour vous vous
pensez que nous sommes en danger et que
la radicalisation dans la police met en
danger non seulement bien sûr les
fonctionnaires de police et également
bien sûr les citoyens je vais je vais
essayer de poser un préambule je suis
pas juge et jury gadio qui fait là des
balles à son bal donc je vais essayer de
faire des réserves
exactement j'aimerais qu'on ne
l'interrompe pas parce qu'on n'est pas
là pour faire une foire d'empoigné
on parle d'un certain sujet très sérieux
il ya eu des morts des familles en deuil
nous sommes tous impactés donc on n'est
pas là pour ce que vous avez bien celui
qui accuse une forte raison tu les as
une petite lésion qu'est ce qui vous a
amené à vous d radicaliser où c'est la
lecture
paradoxalement la détention quand j
arrive on 84 95 70 95 la pénitentiaire
mot signifie que j'ai droit d'emprunter
de livres par semaine j'entends des gens
tentent de par semaine je vais en l'air
deux par jour au moins deux rébellions l
élu de l'histoire est j'ai dis pas qu'il
est tout compris en revanche rien sur
quoi comme type de livre la philosophie
l'histoire la géographie la physique la
chimie le roman et récit j'ai mis de
côté rapidement les classiques grecs
notamment l'iliade et l'odyssée où je
réalise que finalement la nature humaine
est la même qu'il ya 2500 ans et c'est
en lisant que vous êtes dit je fais
fausse route j'ai fait un arrêt cette
demande à ma vision politique des choses
parce qu'en réalité là où les gens
n'arrivent pas à comprendre ce à quoi
nous avons à faire face c'est que nous
pensons avoir affaire à une idéologie
religieuse mais c'est avant tout une
idéologie politique ce n'est pas parce
que quelqu'un se radicalise selon nos
critères
ils arrêtent de manger du porc et la
hâte d'aller en discothèque
il va pas basculer forcément dans une
idéologie politique
ils se rapprochent juste d'une pratique
rigoriste là où il faut être très
vigilant
c'est qu'on peut avoir quelqu'un qui ne
pratiquent pas mais qui valide ce
discours et qui peut passer à l'acte
vous pouvez avoir quelqu'un qui pratique
et qui ne validera pas elle ne passera
pas à l'acte là où je rejoins et madame
et de monsieur c'est que alors quand
vous citer le verset si tu leur en
entier parce qu'on l'entend à chaque
attentat
celui qui a tué un homme tué toutes les
minutes et déjà il s'adresse à banos
israël s'adresse aux enfants d'israël ce
verset pauline julien et parce que
robben texto lice
ok on n'est pas là pour faire des gestes
on n'est pas là pour faire de l'exégète
à deux balles alors s'il vous plaît
quand un site lui pour faire les
théologiens de balle c'est un peu ce que
c'est un peu ce que j'entends sur
plateau puisque oui mais chacun dit
c'est pas des élèves à dire cet avis
discuter a dit on n'y a pas un
professionnel dit alors tout ce qui vous
dérange il
ce qui me dérange c'est que ou non du
pad amalgames on se refuse à nommer les
choses on a un cappuccino on appelle ça
un capitaux à un moment tant que nous ne
nommerons pas correctement
l'énoncé du problème que nous avons à
régler nous ne le régleront pas les noms
c'est correct d'un problème participent
déjà de le régler alors et et vous c'est
quoi les noms c'est correct pour vous
l'énoncé correct c'est que effectivement
il faut pas faire d'amalgamé
mais il ne faut pas de dédouaner l'islam
de ces dérives que je connais parce que
quand on dit le coran et belliqueux ou
le coran et pacifique le camp n'est ni
bellick une île pacifique c'est comme
l'architecturé c'est pas tant le
matériau qui compte que l'agencement que
vous allez en faire
en réalité donc quelqu'un de pacifique
va trouver de quoi nourrir cet esprit là
dans cette lecture quelqu'un de ben ali
quelques va trouver de quoi justifier tu
sais que tu es son prochain c'est que
ces voix là on peut le traduire devant
la ddt c'est valable pour les trois
rôles ils jouent bien sûr il ya qui
viennent nuance alors j'entends aussi 7
à vide avant avant car oui pas dans
votre exposé parce que sa part d'ombré à
quel moment vous vous êtes radicaliser
sur place on you go cela venait en fait
de givet il aurait pu être
je regarde nuit et brouillard à 15 ans
d'accord on ne dit plus jamais ça donc
moins manichéen adolescent je valide ok
plus jamais ça et je vois que ça se
répète en yougoslavie
peu importe que ce soit des bosniaques
musulmans les victimes il aurait pu être
chrétiens orthodoxes catholiques mais
matt et peu importe
subissant ce qu'il subissait je trouve
est insupportable que nous soyons témoin
de sa sans intervenir
maintenant je décide d'y aller 1-2 vous
décidez d'aller comment quand on décide
d'aller et de faire le diable parce que
nous à la comment ça se passe qu'est ce
qui se cache parfois de faire le djihad
je pars avec l'esprit de ceux qui
rejoignent la 27e brigade internationale
en espagne en 1936 c'est sur place comme
j'adore malgré les accords parce que
l'erreur que je fais c'est que je pense
que je vais avoir une action sur le
terrain c'est le terrain qui agit sur
moi et j'ai besoin de me raccrocher une
idéologie qui me permette d'éluder la
terreur de ce que je vois ce que
j'ai eu pour préparer ce que j'ai vu sur
place ça a dépassé ce à quoi je m'étais
préparé donc il m'a fallu une idéologie
qui me disait si tu meurs tu vas au
paradis si tu meurs pas ta le paradis
sur terre puisque tu a vaincu l'ennemi
vous y aviez cru à ça il y avait
clairement parce que j'avais besoin de
ça c'est pour ça que après j'ai validé
le reste mais je me retrouve au pakistan
et en afghanistan
donc vous suffira bien que l'histoire en
afghanistan qu'est ce qui se passe là
bas on a une formation on vous dit quoi
un exemple on nous apprend à fabriquer
une ceinture explosive
donc il ya le volet technique de la
fabrication de celle ci il ya le volet
militaire de l'usaj de celle ci il ya le
volet religieux qui valide son usage
c'est quoi le voile et religieux en fait
bah vous demandez aux maîtres à penser
des salafistes un albanais qui valide
les attentats suicide vous demandez aux
maîtres à penser des frères musulmans le
qaradawi qui valident également
donc vous avez des muftis des gens qui
vous disent vous avez le droit de le
faire et vous sortent une lecture
particulière du coran mais qui est
possible qui vous permet de le faire
donc il vous sera l'inversé legrand qui
vous dit tu vois ce que tu vas faire que
voit ses parts catégorie qui n'a match
tourne tuer les associateurs où vous
voulez trouver sur lattes 9
ça c'est la salade de chevet de tous les
djihadistes donc on vous on vous donne
là le lien dans le coran qui vous permet
de le faire donc à ce volet là il ya le
volet psychologique par exemple là où
c'est très très cynique finalement notre
formateur me repère comme étant moins
bêtes que les autres et il me dit le
jour où tu envoies un candidat à la
ceinture explosive en voile brel envoie
le bon sniper on voit pas le mec capable
de capter mauvais en soi le mauvais non
tu t'en débarrasser un crois donc donc
votre formateur vous a dit c'est kif kif
en vrille et il allait célébrer lé de
côté et il en a choisi quelques-uns en
disant ce que vous devrez envoyer faudra
pas gaspiller le pont sniper faudra pas
gaspiller le gars qui est capable de
capter les communications radio de
l'ennemi il faut pas gaspiller les
sujets du débat là c'est franchement je
savais dès 1000 que j'ai dit je suis
désolée on en plein dedans
la trajectoire est intéressant toujours
pas en quoi ça éclaire le salaire le
débat je lui rappelle simplement que
parmi les terroristes qu'ils soient qui
sont morts soit qui ont été arrêtés on a
retrouvé le coran pour les nuls chez eux
donc c'est pas forcément lié à une étude
à vous laisser répondre alors pas d eric
naulleau c'est pas du tout mineur c'est
l'interview il ou pas de
l'interprétation qui fait que je suis
d'accord avec vous mais là vous avez
perdu ya clan génération de djihadistes
la première était formé par al qaïda qui
voulait former des cadres parce que nous
étions invités en afghanistan s'était
pas un territoire que nous contrôlions
nous étions toléré par les afghans il
nous a menés à manger à boire la journée
nous car nabeul qu'un hardel soir pour
qu'on parte parce que ça se fait pas en
afghanistan lorsque vous inviter
quelqu'un de le dégager
vous pouvez pas le faire
sociologiquement ne pouvait pas le faire
si vous sortez un invité vous ruiner
votre votre nom pour des générations
c'est pour ça qu'ils livrent pas ben
laden pour comprendre savoir quand on
parle donc la première génération ont
formé des cadres capables d'exporter
djihad à l'étranger première génération
deuxième génération on voulait des
opérationnels dans première génération
aux années 70 jusqu'à 2003
l'intervention des états unis en irak
deuxième génération de djihadistes
on veut des opérationnels de terrain
pour combattre les états unis en irak 3e
génération on nadège qui ça va pas le
faire la grimace en deux minutes un
premier mois pour quelqu'un de sérieux
parce que je vous respecte plus
longtemps subi ces espaces mais n'en
dévoie que ça ne se passait pas alors
troisième ne savais pas que mon un
groupe islamiste djihadiste et au nous
expliquer le le jihad pour l'instant il
n'y a aucune preuve ça peut changer
puisqu'on a vu que ça change et le
dossier mais y'a aucune preuve qu'il
était dans une logique djihadistes donc
pour vous
je suis pas d'accord très intéressant
pour comprendre le mécanisme j'essaie de
décerner à comprendre
vous êtes un sachant vous êtes peut-être
un rat de bibliothèque si on arrête de
laboratoire donc à un moment il va
falloir écouter ce qu'il dit la
troisième génération des ch a besoin
d'opérationnel pour gérer un territoire
aussi grand que la belgique avec 11
millions de civils
donc ils descendent le niveau de
recrutement el qaëda disait il faut
d'abord être bon musulman pour être dit
à dist da hd il suffit de jihadistes
pour être bon musulman ça explique qu'on
ait affaire à dia qui la veille et en
discothèque parce que il rachète l'ordre
ils rachètent leur errance avec un
martyr faut savoir qu'en islam c'est la
seule chose qui vous permet d'aller au
pas la seule chose qui vous garantissent
de façon sûre elle au paradis aller au
paradis c'est de mourir en martyrs
d'accord quand vous vendez ça aux gamins
il a une grille qui est une succession
d'échecs et vous lui dites ben si tu
meurs martyrs tu ira au paradis tu sera
pardonnée tu pourras intercéder pour 72
membres de ta famille tu seras au
meilleur niveau du paradis donc on lui
vend une embellie dans sa vie à laquelle
il s'attendait pas il peut la valider à
ce moment là parce que sa vie est un
parcours des chèques
ouais il trouve voyez ce que je veux
dire à ben lui vend la rédemption ça la
vie tu vas là c'est quoi ce que moi de
vous poser de questions mais c'est quoi
la preuve les premières choses qu'on
vous dit et en arrivant au pakistan ou
en afghanistan vous dit quoi
les trois première question c'est
comment veux tu qu'on t'appelle d'accord
qu'il faut faire table rase donc vous
l'appeliez david val à vous appeler
comment là bas je me plais à bon escient
on a rajouté sur place d aérer puisque
ana table design
je parle en arabe dialectal d'accord
j'ai semble-t-il un caractère
d'algériens aussi c'est pour ça qu'on a
appelé la deuxième question c'est quoi
dans une question c'est quel module gris
tu étudié qu'après deuxième question
deuxième question qu'est ce que tu veux
étudier l'accord peut être formé moi je
dis je veux tous vous les to et
troisième question combien tu attends
moi je dis j'ai pas de limite de temps
s'il faut rester un ange reste un an ce
sera quasiment et c'est quoi la journée
type
mais il n'a rien on fait quoi on se lève
le matin très tôt vous êtes dans un dans
un conte c'est un camp avec des tours de
garde l'espoir c'est surveillé six
militaires on se lève le matin ont fait
la prière de phadia du socle ensuite on
fait du sport ce qu'à 9 heures du matin
de 9h à 12h ces entraînements pratique
documentation très fournie sur quoi qui
vous dit quoi sur l'idéologie sur le
matériel on avait des on avait des
manuels d'utilisation d'armes fournies
par la cia désigné par la cia à l'époque
de la lutte contre les soviétiques
mais c'était rester dans nos dents
longues en biotech on va dire donc le
matin cet exercice théorique
l'après-midi exercices pratiques
donc si on apprend le tir d'un missile
sol air le matin l'après midi on va
tirer avec paris d'accord
le soir on désigne qui fait la garde qui
est l'émir la race à celui qui va
désigner les gars qui vont se relever et
c'est comme ça tous les jours
d'accord mesures contraignant intensifs
est ce que vous vous avez fait donc
quatre ans et demi de prison en france
pour association de malfaiteur en
relation de notre lien avec une
entreprise terroriste donc comment vous
avez été interpellé
il n'y a pas de mandat d'arrêt
concernant parce que avant de me
convertir j'étais un peu trop de ce
qu'ils sont on va dire et j'avais lu que
lénine disait que lorsque l'on menait
des actions de subversion
il fallait toujours s'attendre à être
infiltré il y aurait forcément un agent
de l'état combattre est parmi nous mais
je m'étais inventé un personnage rachid
d'algérie vous aviez trois personnages
ou même david après quand vous avez en
afghanistan rachid donc du coup tout le
monde le connaissait sous ce prénom là
d'accord j'ai passé un tram et comme
vous avez été arrêté pour que vous avez
arrêté ce que le mandat d'arrêt
était à l'encontre de la personne chez
qui je me trouvais ce matin là vous avez
été arrêtés ou chasse-sur-rhône d'accord
donc derrière donc fait quatre ans et
demi de prison la juge me confirmera que
je sors dans l'instruction comme le
lapin du chapeau du magicien
d'accord il ne cherchait pas en fait
voyez vous on trouvait hier les
arachides
alors qu'on trouve que vous avez pensé
des attentats contre charlie hebdo le
bataclan les terrasses parisiennes
à l'époque vous étiez diest le crazy
prévisible vous étiez c'était prévisible
évidemment le 14 juillet à nice était
prévisible
évidemment on laisse une doctrine avoir
lieu librement se diffuser alors on
refuse que vous auriez pu être une de
ces personnes vous nous auriez peut être
un des alors il y avait à l'école à
l'époque avait 2 et kool shen à reda il
ya ceux qui disaient qu'il fallait
frapper uniquement les représentants de
représentation de l'état
moi j'étais de ceux-là d'accord
police/gendarmerie magistrats élus dont
vous auriez peut être un mickaël harper
à l'époque
ouais parfaitement d'accord il y avait
ceux qui disaient que il faut frapper
les populations pour semer la terreur
de sorte que le pacte républicain est
républicain soit rompu c'est un peu ce
que préconisait madame tout à la faire
attention de monsieur également faut
faire attention de ne pas nous diviser
parce que c'est le but recherché c'est
le but recherché
on cherche tous à trouver des solutions
qui nous laisse dans la cohésion est pas
dans la division mais ne pas nommer les
choses ne nous permettra pas de trouver
une solution et non mais permet de
trouver une solution alors on attaque
david on va on va revenir on va vous ré
interroger au cours bien sûr de cette
émission puisqu'on parle de la
radicalisation dans la police omon en
danger je vois qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de réactions sur
twitter sûr je voudrais témoigner de
david a précisé un truc là lucine je
pense que nous ne sommes pas en danger
mais il faut prendre le coup de semonce
très au sérieux parce que le logiciel
est là même si aujourd'hui je suis un
laïc républicain acharné il y a un peu
comme quelqu'un qui se serait fait
reculer d'un membre le fantôme pias donc
j'ai toujours ce logiciel gère le
contrôle de suez reprendra pas le dessus
donc si j'avais été liés à cette
opération je ne pense pas que ce soit
une opération mandatée padash ils sont
pas en capacité de le faire pour
l'instant
il faudra qu'ils récupéreront penser que
c'est un acte isolé c'est un acte isolé
parce que si jamais mon
si j'avais été le gars qui a eu accès
aux infos je les aurais dit j'aurais
diffusé le nom et les adresses de
certains fonctionnaires de police pour
rajouter de la terreur ce que l'objectif
il était là militaire la ferme ça n'a
pas été différent sur la raison diffusé
donc il a passé six mois j'étais le gars
qui a les informations s'ils existent je
ne pense pas que ce soit le cas ils ont
été rajoutés à la terreur
j'aurais déjà diffusés les adresses et
les noms de quelques agents concernés ce
vous rajoutez à la terreur pour rajouter
la visualisation commissariat ils ont
pas rendues et le comment dire là ils
ont pas rendu les données publiques
bon mais il ya eu un choix apparemment
de quai des appels qui ont été reçus
dans des commissariats de banlieue
parisienne en particulier qui sont en
cours d'authentification
non alors ça vous avez pas ta vie est ce
que je vais leur histoire les ouvriers
tous vous entend pas là on va reprendre
depuis le début et oui vous dit pas non
je disais moi je suis très impressionné
par votre témoignage
j'aurais dis franchement c'est la
première fois c'est la première fois sur
un plateau de télévision ou même chassé
d'accord j'entends avec autant de clarté
et me semble utile de précision même si
je ne connais pas évidemment ce sujet
comme vous connaissez et j'ai appris
énormément de choses ce soir c'est
incroyable ce qu'il a dit quand il a dit
il on voit les laisser les plus mauvais
exceptionnelle entre guillemets c'est à
dire que vous avez une connaissance de
l'intérieur de ce phénomène qu'on ne
sait pas par quel bout prendre en fait
on france à chaque fois qu'ils en
attendent et c'est dans le texte mais
c'est sa voix qui me sidère
mais est-ce que je teste en danger
aujourd'hui david g2 fatwa mais j'ai une
gastro chaque hiver ça m'empêche pas de
dormir
vraiment ça vous a dû m'en tamponne que
ça vous fait peur vraiment je la menace
de me tuer ne me fait que rappeler
l'engagement de mon seigneur qui va me
rappeler à lui donc les mecs me menace
de ce que je sais c'est inéluctable
puisque peu de monnaie aujourd'hui vous
voulez faire aujourd'hui vous
voulez-vous les combats jalu je suis
chargé d'affaires dans l'industrie je
paye la pension alimentaire de ma fille
je paye mon loyer j'ai pas de subvention
pas dead pas de pas de soutiens pas
d'argent je paye de ma poche de mai
denier mon action je suis dans une
situation financière très délicate avec
deux athlètes religieux ça me regarde
j'ai envie de vous dire savoir rien mais
ce que vous êtes et ce que vous êtes
toujours aussi entre man et vieux condé
par une ellipse on va dire vous étiez
très religieux avant trop tron
certainement trop vous êtes toujours
religieux ça me regarde privé donc oui
ça me regarde c'est de l'ordre du privé
cirque aujourd'hui m'avait serveurs
temps passe alors je vais je vais vous
dire un peu ce que je pense aujourd'hui
et concernant et je vais je vais
répondre au palais ma raison m'apporte
ma réflexion m'apporte la réponse à
comment le monde
ma femme apporte la réponse à pourquoi
le monde je mélange pas les deux
d'accord alors que matt est vrai bien
sûr me sert à comment le monde pour le
monde
j'ai les réponses dans ma religion ne
l'êtes religieux les impose à personne